[Música]
si nos acerca a ello no lo voy a hacer
se vaya a pensar que me gusta o algo
cuatro horas tardado en contestarme el
whatsapp hasta mañana no pienso
escribirle
nada si no lo conozco tan solo nos hemos
acostado
cómo funciona persona de 20 25 años hoy
día como son estas relaciones como
interaccionamos los jóvenes de hoy en
día no aguantan nada no saben lo que es
el amor no tiene principios pero de
verdad sólo vamos a peor de verdad somos
seres tan vacíos como es el amor hoy hay
amor
ortega y gasset que me encanta por
cierto entendían la realidad según el
perspectivismo hablaba de que cada uno
era uno y su circunstancia por lo tanto
el concepto de realidad era que
diferente para cada persona él hablaba
de que teníamos uno como unas lentes
como una ventana al mundo hoy no vengo
otra cosa que a poneros mis gafas a
contar en mi experiencia ya que veis el
amor desde mi ventana
para poneros un poco en contexto mi
primera relación estable duró tres años
desde los 17 hasta los 20 fue una
relación sana estable madura de
confianza fue una persona muy especial
para mí y aprende mucho con él
pero ambos sentíamos que teníamos muchas
inquietudes yo sentía que necesitaba
conocer más y no son los chicos sentía
que necesitaba madurar sola
al haber crecido con él eso año están
importantes de mi vida sentí un poco
como que mis proyectos y mi sueño no
eran sólo míos me sentí un poco una
copia barata de
hicimos las cosas al mismo tiempo y
vimos una buena oportunidad para volar
solos
erasmus fue intenso yo llegué allí con
muchas ganas de conocer gente no veía
todo mi amigos tienen su relación
abierta su rollo
vaya torta me pegue allí y bueno aquí
también pasa la gente jugaba un juego al
que yo no sabía jugar ahora no te
contesto te pongo celoso hablando con no
sé quién relaciones abiertas nada serio
sólo físico
fatal o sea no se me dio nada bien
una de las noches que fue muy
significativa para mí fue el halloween
de 2016 yo llevaba nada apenas un mes en
coche en polonia y nada nos disfrazamos
nuestra fiesta discoteca
y allí en medio de la discoteca con
todos mis amigos con todo comencé a
llorar
pero además no un llanto desesperado
ruidoso sino eran lágrimas cayendo
mi amigo imaginaron no sé a qué te pasa
está súper alarmado
pero yo
yo lloraba de vacío
lloraba viendo el panorama de amigos
compartiendo chicos de todos con todos
del 'todo vale' sentía como si a todo el
mundo le diera igual todo como si
fuéramos trozos de carne que no sienten
absolutamente nada
yo sentía tanto y me costaba tanto
anestesiar men nunca había tenido que
ocultar lo que sentía o jugar ese juego
tan absurdos en el que perdía el que se
enamoraba
o un chico que me encantó me volvió loca
pero claro el estado de lagos en toda
regla
yo intenté adaptarme hace meses que me
da igual eso lo físico
una de las primeras veces que estábamos
quedando que a mí me ponía súper
nerviosa aunque yo no quisiera porque me
atacaba
quedaba muy tal y me decía estás súper
nerviosa estaba atacada está temblando
la cara me puso el espejo delante y ahí
estaba yo con mi cara
me ponía mal y si más no
era muy fue de cuestionarme todo y
aprender mucho después de darle muchas
vueltas a todo llegue a la determinación
de que yo no sé jugar a ese juego de no
sentir y además sí más importante no
quería aprender a hacerlo le dije este
chico qué bueno que cada uno por su
cuenta no que a mí las cosas a medias no
me iban curioso como en la vida que él
al final pues se acabó pillando por mí y
decidimos tener una relación que además
duró un año más después de nuestro
éramos
esta relación fue muy intensa y a
distancia
que también
él es una persona que le costaba mucho
abrirse además de que odiaba dise
vulnerable o sea era algo con lo que no
podía me cuestionen o qué papel tan
crucial tiene la vulnerabilidad de las
relaciones esa confianza ciega donde se
aprende tanto y se pasa tan mal a veces
esa que nos da tantísimo vértigo a todos
lo cierto es que teníamos que hacer muy
fuerte los dos y formas de creer muy
diferentes y bueno fue una de las
razones por la que decidimos dejarlo a
esta altura pensé es curioso como he
podido querer a estos dos chicos tan
tanto y con la misma intensidad pero de
maneras tan diferentes que me tiré mucho
tiempo intentando definir el amor pero
qué tontería no incluso la experiencia
es diferente con cada persona
tras esta relación tan intensa que
promete intensa jornada fue el mayo
pasado
en mi examen y mi estudio y dije yo no
no me saturé de un poco de todo un día
recibió un correo de la universidad
charlas ted en cádiz y me encanta me
flipa meter apuntadas y así fui con tam
ilusión y el tema el amor frío toma lo
que yo quería en este momento de mi vida
pero estas cosas nunca salen súper
ilusionada a mirar lo que no cabía en mi
casa era algo que me emocionaba un
montón desde el organización me dijeron
y descansa el verano nos pondremos a
tope en septiembre ahora mismo cargar
pilas descansa y nos pondremos ya a tope
cuando cuando volvamos otra cosa que se
me da fatal a mí cuando algo me ilusiona
yo no sé dosificarme sea el amor ya era
un tema que a mí me quita el sueño ahora
imaginaros tenía que hablar de me
quitaba el sueño me quitaba el hambre
evita todo yo no no no no podía
era un tema complicado mi tema era el
amor el amor en los jóvenes y mi
sensación era negativa tenía una
sensación mala y además hablando con mis
amigos eran malas también sean los
mismos porque no pero era negativa la
como va a ser mala no si ahora mismo
tenemos mucha más libertad o sea se han
quitado muchísimo estigma la solterona
de hoy no en las otras 50 años de una
persona libre que elige y disfruta su
vida como quiere las personas del mismo
sexo celebra su amor públicamente las
chicas ya no busca un príncipe azul
puede ser morado violeta y fontanero el
sexo ya no es un tabú puedes tener un
novio dos a la vez o una relación
abierta sin compromiso vivimos en la era
del todo vale mientras se ha acordado en
teoría y sé que suena raro somos la
generación más fiel
porque en realidad cuando algo no nos
gusta no reparamos en tirarlo y hace una
camiseta unos vaqueros o el chico con la
que estaba que da estos meses
simplemente se apagó la llama no
quería analizar quería investigar quería
desde organización le dijeron también
oye no queremos una socióloga habríamos
buscado
queremos una chica de 22 años hablando
de amor pero yo necesitaba comprender
por qué hacemos tanto el tonto
todo esto además se mezclado imaginaros
en verano con todos los cotilleos y
todas las historias que sus clientes
amigo a mí ya todo me parecía analizable
por ejemplo me llama un amigo me decía
que estoy con pepito y con su padre que
hemos venido a comer y tal pero me ha
invitado a ir a almería con ellos yo no
sé que se pensarán
y claro yo para mí pensando chica un año
quedando competido día sí día también
aguarda infidelidad y está comiendo con
sus padres al no sé quién lo que se van
a pensarlo
en qué momento el amor ha pasado a ser
un tabú cuando el sexo dejado de serlo
porque nos da tanto miedo o yo que sé
qué decir que es tu novio porque no es
que haga tanto porque sólo pica y el
compromiso
o quedaba con otro amigo y me decía
sabes chip y no recuerdo la última vez
que me lié con alguien sobrio
impacta pero todos sabemos que no es
ninguna locura idea no es ninguna locura
que es el alcohol una excusa un
desinhibidor está claro quizá es una
forma de lidiar con una cierta
incapacidad para sociabilizar no sé yo
intentando explicarlo todos sabemos
tienen que es un escritorio y un coach
británico que también ha dado varias te
hablaba de que un uso temprano y
compulsivo de redes sociales entorpecía
el desarrollo de las habilidades
sociales y hablaba de la generación
millennials nosotros como una generación
carente de esas relaciones humanas
reales se alcohol una forma de cubrir
esas incapacidades no sé yo creando mis
teorías en el aire
todo tengo que decirles a mí las redes
sociales me encantan yo soy muy fan de
instagram por ejemplo y además me gustan
las publicaciones con letras los grandes
los que hay que leer me encanta áfrica y
los guardo los seleccionan y de vez en
cuando pues me siento y me pongo a leer
los toma en cuenta me di cuenta que tras
todo esos techos de letras hay un
bombardeo continuo de mensajes y lo vi
dije juego
hay un bombardeo continuo de que nadie
te cambio no dependas de nadie no te
hace falta nadie para ser feliz baja
completa etcétera bombardeo
una profundiza esto y de qué tontería
estamos hablando no como tu pareja no te
va a afectar nada en absoluto como no
vamos a depender de ella en nada ya que
es una pareja que es el amor creo que el
amor de hoy está un poco individualizado
o también percibí en redes sociales un
sentimiento muy fuerte de carpe diem
viajar y disfrutar de tu momento tus
proyectos tus sueños tu vida tú tú tú
quiero que a veces también nos volvemos
un poco egoísta the times en 2013 nos
bautiza como la generación del yo yo yo
no me confundáis quiero hacer aquí un
paréntesis se atoró nuestra generación o
sea una vez de verdad me me creí que
éramos personas vacías y superficiales
pero no es cierto siempre se ha dicho
que la generación presente es peor la
anterior sócrates ya la base de la
juventud hace 2500 años son una
generación completamente internacional
compartimos idioma y culturas diferentes
hay muchísimo más respeto por el
desigual y no solo respeto sino una
inmensa curiosidad por el mundo
es mucho más fácil viajar ahora y aunque
aunque no quiera moverte ahora somos por
todas partes es tarea difícil ser un
estrecho demente de día aunque muchos lo
consiguen
son una generación que no busca un
trabajo fijo o un gran sueldo sino
disfrutar el tiempo que estamos aquí
carpe diem y es maravilloso de hecho es
pelea diaria con mi padre para que sepa
saborear el presente y el trabajo no lo
consuma tanto
pero creo que irónicamente ese carpe día
nos impide disfrutar muchas cosas
el carpe diem que entendemos hoy no
entiende de compromiso o de cultivar
algo por un largo periodo de tiempo o de
renunciar a algo por alguien el cartón
de hoy entiende de hoy de esta noche y
de notar tema van porque la vida son los
días oye y que viven las cosas de una
noche pero bienvenido aquí a hablar de
amor y no de sexo
con todo el tema de la de la charla y
tal se me ocurrió hacer una encuesta
realmente se le ocurrió a mi madre pero
bueno hice una encuesta no esperaba
mucha participación era verano el tema
del amor sano
no es representativa ni oficial ni uso
aquí ningún dato pero en tan sólo 24
horas obtuve 170 respuestas y en 20 días
más de 850 ya cientos de conceptos y
reflexiones sobre qué es el amor y qué
cambios se han hecho en uno mismo muchos
que me pusieron los pelos de punta qué
es lo que nos pasa cuando la va a jugar
ánimo es curioso
seguí investigando quería quería meterme
en ella no pensaba que bien problemas
problemas desde muy de cerca quiere
saber quiénes somos los millennials o
qué factores nos hacen actuar cómo
actuamos que no sé qué educarse como
recibido quiénes hacen nuestros padres
qué entorno hemos no se ve origen el
verano fue intenso muy intensa
por ejemplo en mi caso mi educación
mis padres tuvieron muchas creencias en
su infancia y han querido que a mí no me
faltará de nada siempre con mucho
hincapié en que me curara y supiera
valorar todas mis cosas pero sí que lo
tiene mucho más fácil que ellos
consideró que vivimos en la era de la
inmediatez que cuando queremos algo lo
tenemos y es el objeto programación
conversaciones por whatsapp relaciones
sexo y creo que a veces nos ponemos unos
impacientes queremos que todo funcione
ya cuando las mejores cosas de la vida
requieren tiempo y trabajo
y es que esperamos alguien especial y es
que hoy en día no hay nada típico no
que espera que venga un cartel luminoso
interesante que la tuya no sé o sea no
creó el alma gemela
no creo que dios o quien se haya
colocado a alguien el mundo para ti
creo que la convivencia se curra que el
amor es trabajo es cultivo de una
balanza de cosas buenas y malas que
compartes con alguien que hacen tu vida
más bella
no sé socióloga lo sé sólo quería
comprender en qué momento se ha vuelto
mucho más íntimo tomarse un café con
alguien que acostarse
pensadlo no con cualquiera quedáis a
solas sobrios para tomar un café y
charlar de la vida es mucho más íntimo
es desnudarse de verdad
lo cierto que el tema me satura un poco
me sobrepasó un poco un día que tengo
unas amigas para merendar 5 de la tarde
con esas las cosas no puede quedar de
otra manera lo de la mañana su pizzería
no sé cómo empezar con un chico
americano de la base naval de aquí de
cádiz empezamos a hablar nos contamos
nuestra vida en verso empezamos a hablar
de la vida de la muerte de dios
no intento nada conmigo o sea ningún
tipo de aproximación lo cual te resulta
extraño porque está en un bar al lado de
la mañana pero no sé y sabré conmigo de
par en par le dijo todo lo que pensaba y
sentía sea súper extraña hecha porque la
semana junto su compañero se volvieron a
la base y tal vez ya que se quedaba
me reí como hacía tiempo me reía
desconecte de mi charla de lo complejo
de las relaciones de lo complejo del
amor no pasa absolutamente nada
para su realista se ha llevado de la
mano por cádiz se dormía la siesta a mi
lado claro que sí tiene semana con mis
amigos que me da la mano con tu amigo
digo
claro mi amiga con la que había quedado
de anterior de mi la demencia
lo que no me contaste no es capaz aquí
os lo preguntaban cuánto tiempo llevas y
yo lo conocía y les dijo o sea no lo sé
fue totalmente surrealista luego en la
base fue de misión a israel por ahí y
las cosas que todavía fueron sólo dos
días pero este chico me recordó lo
simple no
en realidad el amor lo que se gana
apostamos por las personas jugando tela
abriéndote tomando café y desnudando el
alma
como veis me estoy quedando
absolutamente el pelotas a vista os lo
he contado todo o sea me da mucho miedo
abrirme de esta manera y me siento
vulnerable en cierta forma pero creo que
no podía defender que tenemos que
abrirnos sin dar un poquito el ejemplo
sabéis que veo de todo esto de toda
nuestra relación es historias de amores
y aventuras
veo crecimiento vio madurez voy personas
más ricas por lo que han pasado en
vivido nunca he aprendido y crecido
tanto como mis relaciones donde me sentí
totalmente desprotegidas y vulnerables
hoy solo quiero pediros que dejemos
hacer el tonto que las cosas de las
noches también son divertidas pero que
si quieres que vayan a más no dejes de
hacerlo por miedo o por que no se lleve
las cosas serias que el que se enamora
no pierde el que siente ganas que nos
tome un café
[Aplausos]
[Música]